se trata manifiestamente de un ataque
terrorista de tipo islamista así se
refirió el ministro del interior francés
ya la manada en una entrevista con la
televisión pública francesa al ataque
que tuvo lugar esta mañana en contra de
la antigua sede del periódico satírico
saliendo y en el que resultaron heridas
dos personas por arma blanca de hermanan
dijo que había preguntado también a los
prefectos si quizás no se había
subestimado la amenaza que pesaba en
contra este lugar simbólico en momentos
en que tiene lugar en parís el juicio
por los atentados de enero del año 2015
uno de los cuales afectó a la revista
satírica en el plano policial una
persona ha sido detenida como el
presunto autor de los ataques se trata
de un joven paquistaní de 18 años que
había llegado apenas hace tres años a
francia como un menor no acompañado en
agosto había cumplido su mayoría de edad
y aunque no tiene antecedentes por
radicalización si tiene antecedentes
policiales por porte de arma otra
persona fue detenido durante el ataque
un argelino de 33 años la policía está
tratando de establecer su vínculo con
los ataques y cinco personas fueron
detenidas durante la tarde cuando se
allanó el domicilio del presunto
en la zona de pantano esto es en el
noreste de parís